bonsoir très blanche maison merci d'être
avec nous bruxelles qui donc sort sa
boîte à outils un pour tenter d'alléger
les factures des des européens l'union
européenne qui met quand même la
responsabilité sur sur les états avec
notamment l'incitation à baisser la tva
et les taxes sur l'énergie ça revient
dans dans la proposition de certains
candidats à la présidentielle en france
est-ce que c'est réalisable selon vous
oui l'espagne l'a fait l'espagne a
baissé sa tva de 19 à 10 % et les taxes
spécifiques sur l'énergie de 5 des
poussières à 0 5% donc puisque l'espagne
la fessée c'est possible l'espagne ne
s'en tient pas là d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle demande d'autres mesures
européennes
elle demande notamment des achats
groupés de gaz un peu comme il y avait
eu les achats groupés de vaccins alors
la france elle a pris une voie beaucoup
plus moyennes qui consiste à
plafonner le prix du le prix du gaz pour
pour six mois à limiter la hausse de
l'électricité à 4% en janvier et c'est
ce qu'on appelle le fameux bouclier
castex qui consiste en fait à répercuter
la hausse en l'étalant sur l'année
prochaine sur l'année 2022 et puis il ya
les chèques énergie 100 à 150 euros pour
environ 6 millions de ménages qui se
trouve dans la difficulté mais il
apparaît effectivement que c'est
insuffisant
l'allemagne pour sa part évidemment fils
est réel même considère que le marché va
rétablir l'équilibré puisque la demande
va se stabilise et que par conséquent
les prix vont baisser au printemps c'est
d'ailleurs aussi l'analyse française
mais l'allemagne considère qu'il faut
laisser le marché faire les pays du nord
de l'europe sont du même avis et la
boîte à outils de la commission peut
servir aux états membres à bricoler
puisque une boîte à outils s'est fait
tout ça mais ils ont déjà fait ce qu'ils
veulent le faire l'ont déjà fait et
continueront à le faire cela dit lien
conseil européen en huit jours et là je
pense que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement vont se retrouver
confrontés
et vous avez évoqué ce point pour la
question la proche des problèmes la
campagne française ils vont se
confronter au vrai sujet c'est à dire
est-ce qu'on peut prendre des mesures
plus fortes pour soutenir le revenu des
ménages des particuliers est-ce qu'on
peut prendre de vraies mesures
européennes qui constitueraient les
éléments de politique commune de
l'énergie parce que justement ce que
vous vous dites un l'optimisme français
allemand le marché va réguler les choses
on imagine plutôt à la baisse selon eux
est ce que vous y croyez ou est-ce qu'au
contraire cette envolée des prix est ce
que ça peut perdurer très haut et se
stabilise et très haut dans le temps
bon ça va ça va ça va durer insérer un
certain temps bien entendu d'autant plus
que l'allemagne qui est sorti déjà du
nucléaire qui doit sortir du charbon
d'ici 2038 va avoir besoin de plus en
plus de gaz pour gérer sa transition et
transition énergétique
mais c'est temporaire à long terme bien
sûr
cette transition énergétique doit
déboucher sur des énergies non carbonées
or l'union européenne a adopté un
objectif pour 2050 après tout ça n'est
pas si loin d'avoir une économie
européenne
complètement décarbonée alors ça veut
dire bien entendu plus de charbon mais
ça veut dire aussi à ce moment là très
peu de gaz et par conséquent des recours
a recours à des énergies renouvelables
et pour ceux qui l'acceptent dont la
france évidemment l'énergie nucléaire
est ce que dans cette configuration peut
parler d'une menace plus globale sur
la reprise économique
oka reprise économique est indépendant
de ce facteur parce que le poids de
l'énergie dans dans la dans la feu dans
les coûts de fabrication est quand même
relativement limité la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est surtout pour les
ménages qui ne peuvent plus payer leurs
factures à la fin du mois et dans les
pays bas et j'ai séance électorale c'est
particulièrement grave bien sûr mais je
ne pense pas que ceci entrave la reprise
la reprise économique qui déjà
et bien en cours avec les plans de
relance nationaux le plan relance
européens qui sont en train de produire
leurs effets et nous sommes toujours
avec un claude blanchemaison on vient de
voir un taux de la crise des prix du gaz
qui était au coeur du forum énergétique
à moscou pour vladimir poutine on
rappelle en et les européens ont commis
l'erreur de se reposer sur la main
invisible du marché quel rôle peut jouer
la russie dans cette crise je crois que
le prénom russe a dit trois choses
importantes et il a appelé un fait
historique c'est-à-dire la fiabilité des
fournitures russes de gaz il a même
rappelé qu'à l'époque de l'union
soviétique à l'époque de la guerre
froide et bien moscou avait toujours
respecté ses engagements contractuels en
matière de fourniture de gaz et en effet
gage de france qui est devenue angie
aujourd'hui rappelle que les rapports
étaient très étroits avec as prom est en
effet à l'époque essentiellement sous la
forme de contrats à long terme alors
c'est son deuxième point c'est que il
estime que l'union européenne a eu grand
tort de réduire la part des contrats à
long terme 10 20 30 ans pour préférer
l'instantanéité des marchés le marché
spot comme on le dit et effectivement
les proportions se sont tout à fait
inverser et aujourd'hui les opérateurs
préfèrent avoir une grande partie de
leur business qui passe par le marché
spot les opérateurs sont pas les états
ce sont les grandes sociétés qui
fournissent les hydrocarbures et par
conséquent on ne peut pas leur donner
des injonctions ce sont les sociétés
privées qui cherche bien entendu à
opérer à maxime et leurs profits dans le
long terme donc c'est un problème
important mais c'est un sujet qui
devrait être discuté sans doute avec la
russie on voit aussi que certains pays
ont proposé que la commission
face dans le fond des groupements
d'achat de gaz qui serait probablement
du gaz russe c'est un sujet à discuter
qui est assez novateur
mais on voit bien que la russie est
prête à évoquer tous ces sujets que dans
l'immédiat gazprom est prêt à ouvrir un
peu le robinet de façon à faciliter le
retour à une situation normale sur le
marché européen d'ailleurs la seule
annonce qui a été faite par le président
russe a une incidence immédiate sur les
cours du gaz les cours du gaz ont baissé
parce que ça a été considéré comme un
apport qui a annoncé en effet la rentrée
de la russie dans le jeu alors autre
piste peut-être vous allez nous le dira
le nouveau gazoduc nord stream ii est ce
qui pourrait aider lui aussi à rectifier
le tir oui c'est un moyen parmi d'autres
parce que bien sûr la russie exporte son
gaz par des gazoducs ceux qui traversent
l'ukraine et monsieur poutine l'avait
évoqué il ya quelques jours également
dans ce colloque sur le gaz et bien sûr
il faut les utiliser nord stream un qui
fonctionne à plein régime et nord stream
2 qui pourra fonctionner dès que
l'autorité de régulation allemande lui
aura donné sa bénédiction c'est à dire
et qu'il aurait été déclarée conforme et
ça devrait arriver sans doute sous peu
de temps évidemment puisqu'ils un
conseil européen à la fin de la semaine
prochaine ces sujets vont aussi être
évoquée et certains états membres vont
vouloir l'évoquer sous un aspect
politique et pas nécessairement sous un
aspect on énergétique merci beaucoup
claude la blanche maison d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir